following alabama's near a total ban on
abortion Missouri is expected to join
the wave of states passing anti-abortion
legislation later today
Zuri's bail out Laos a procedure after 8
weeks of pregnancy now this would become
the fifth state this year to enact a
so-called fetal heartbeat bill adriana
DS diaz rather spoke to people on both
sides of this issue it is one of the
most egregious overreaches of
governmental regulation that I have ever
seen dr. David Eisenberg is the medical
director at the only abortion clinic
left in Missouri
he says abortion restrictions only
endanger women who were bound to get
abortions anyway those regulations do
not make anybody healthier they do not
protect people who need abortion care
they just make it harder to get it
Missouri's abortion laws are already
among the strictest in the nation and if
the supreme court overturns roe versus
wade the new bill would automatically
ban all abortions the calls are just
coming constantly the phone is ringing
off the hook
Kawana shannon is the director of social
services at the st. louis clinic
she says patients have been calling
asking if abortions are still legal this
bill if turned into law will allow women
to have abortions earlier on do you
think that's not enough no it's not
enough a lot of women don't find out and
so they're already past that time but
Missouri's anti-abortion advocates argue
the bill is meant to protect women
especially those with fewer means most
women don't want an abortion and the
number one reason that they feel they
have no choice is because they don't
have the finances the bill increases tax
credits for donations to Pregnancy
Resource Center's clinics that
discourage women from having abortions
and provide emotional and material
support women who receive abortions
after eight weeks would not be
prosecuted but doctors who performed
them could face up to 15 years in prison
and potentially lose their medical
licenses supporters of the bill say it's
worth it I had to be comfortable with
the fact that it's legal to abort a
child in this great country of ours and
so if that is the law of the land I'll
be comfortable with that too for CBS
this morning Adriana Diaz st. Louis
Missouri